[Music]
i tried watching the the new purge
and i got to that scene i was dying
laughing
where'd you learn how to use that
she just dabs yeah she's just like okay
i i fell asleep man did you really i
mean i smoked a little bit before so
um that's the only reason i brought up
the stories to let you know that i smoke
weed
okay sick
[ __ ] yeah so we can move on yeah
i remember a time where i smoked weed
that's cool yeah did you get high yeah
yeah
i bet i've been higher than you though i
mean i was pretty high
how high were you like really high like
how high on a scale of like one to ten
like ten okay yeah i was a ten two i was
probably like ten point one then yeah i
mean if the skill went higher i would be
higher on the scale but it doesn't go
higher
what how rgb depends how high the skill
goes
if you put a number on it well let's say
one to what
100 it'd be 100 okay
i'd probably be 101 then well the scale
doesn't go that high yeah but i like
tipped the scale
that's not really what that phrase means
but that's how high i am right now oh
okay you're high right now yeah i'm
always high yeah same always
[Laughter]
anyway so i smoked weed
that's all this podcast is a stoner
pissing match
yeah just delta variance kicking my ass
i've been rolling up like every day
though yeah no big yeah no it was like i
woke up with a fever and so obviously
first thing i do is hit my bubbler like
i always do
and
as i breathe it out i cough
right and i normally i cough because i'm
smoking pure
oil
but right like
yeah yeah and so i'm smoking like just
straight up like the strongest most
concentrated weed you possibly can for
sure right and i'm dabbing it yeah right
taking dabs yeah so i finished my dab
and i start coughing like i normally do
because i'm smoking dabs yeah and i
realize this cough goes on for a little
bit too long which it normally does
because of the dabs that i smoke yeah
and then i realize it's going on too
long and it was the covet
that sucks yeah so i had the munchies
like super bad because i was so high
right but i couldn't leave the place
because i thought i knew i could i'd
covet yeah
yeah i've pretty much circumvented
coughing and all that i'm like literally
the most progressive stoner on earth no
one knows that though
i've built like a essentially like a
neural network that taps directly into
the marijuana leaf with small syringes
so i directly get the thc creation and
then i needle it into my arm
oh
you shoot up weed i shoot up weed holy
[ __ ] yeah all right you win yeah and
then some days when i'm feeling crazy
like i'll just stick a needle in my
lungs
wow
yeah of
smoke
of thc it just like it's like a drip
method it just drips directly into my
lungs
yeah
by the way
we got like it doesn't really work if
you filled your lungs with fluid would
you be that's pneumonia yeah you would
die but that's why i want weed pneumonia
so like when i do cough it up yeah
weed
[Laughter]
it's just
weed water yeah when i spit it out into
my bong and light it
self-feeding system so sick yeah
honestly so anyways fellow stoners just
wanna let you all know like i was high
yeah while watching the new purging the
new purge you didn't make it through
because you were so hyped so [ __ ] i
fell asleep
i mean it was i don't know it was good
what was the ending
um
what was the ending i was so high i
don't remember
oh they all go to mexico that's right
yeah yeah yeah yeah oh yeah that's the
whole like this giant circle on the
whole thing is that like the guy who's
exactly yeah the dude who's like
anti-mexican or anti-immigration or
whatever finally
you know takes uh you know protection
and
whoa
so it's like well you kind of have to
appreciate it the last two purge is just
adopting bad
political
angles on ships well no it's good
because it teaches you that racism is
not a good thing
right yeah so through the purge exactly
yeah yeah yeah it would take yeah that's
that's all it takes is a sheer meltdown
of all so like society and social
construct yeah to finally realize
oh
racism is bad
yeah that's what the point of the movie
is
it's for people to watch and finish and
go
you know han
mexicans aren't that bad
that's what it's for
that's what i want people to do and then
each installment of the film after just
highlighting a different race of people
yeah exactly yeah chinese people aren't
that bad yeah you know what
i get it now you know the next purge is
going to be like some pandemic [ __ ] it's
going to be some poor taste pandemic
yeah they're just waiting like a year or
two yeah in three years oh man the
amount of pandemic concepts
it's just gonna
everyone's gonna be about it yeah i know
and and we will
watch those movies yeah
actually i don't know man
do you see that quote from uh
i forgot what actor was saying it'd be
like oh movies aren't going to be part
of kids lives like they were for us
how so it was matt damon or something
yeah
i didn't really read his reasoning but
it's already different it's already so
different like
i don't think
i think he talked to his kid for the
first time in like five years okay
that's why he's getting all this
publicity
who matt damon damon i mean i was gonna
say like it already is
so different in the way that like i mean
this is actually a good segue into the
scarlett johansson suing disney mm-hmm
for you know royalties yeah what was the
movie black widow
yeah yeah they like it was in theaters
for two weeks or something and they put
it on demand which is like every movie
now corella fast nine yep space jam
they're all you can rent it for 20 bucks
online and i think it'll just be like
that forever so there's not gonna be
like this big
movie release
you know two period of two months where
everyone goes out and sees it unless
it's an a24 film
yeah yeah green knight is in theaters
only right now yeah yeah what is green
night what is that the green knight um
it's like a fantasy movie okay i forget
the premise but i want to go watch it
but i have to go to the theater ah
anyway so yeah they all flee to mexico
right yeah and then that's the end and
then his daughter's born there and then
that's it yeah and then he basically is
like a new man
yeah it's pretty absurd how like
i don't know just like tropey
it is yeah
it's still an entertaining like the
violence is entertaining no 100 percent
he's like you don't like me because i'm
mexican he's like saying because you're
mexican
i just feel like we shouldn't mix it's
like that didn't make it better i know
he's like
you know you stay where you were born
and i'll stay where i'm born like well
that's
it's kind of the same thing yeah
it doesn't change what the [ __ ] you just
said
you know what i uh started watching is
white lotus have you seen that no oh
damn write that down the new hbo show
it is bizarre
[ __ ] bizarre
because it's one of those shows where
nothing really happens uh-huh you find
out at the very beginning that someone
is gonna die okay somewhere during the
show that's the first scene and then it
flips back
so you're watching this whole thing
unfold knowing that someone is gonna die
at some point
but
nothing happens like it's just this
weird
intertwining of like five different
storylines of people at this resort in
hawaii okay and they all kind of like
cross paths every once in a while
but like it's one of those shows that
like keeps it makes you so uncomfortable
and it keeps feel it keeps feeling like
it's going to build up to something yeah
but it doesn't it never gives you that
release so you're constantly sitting
there and then the episode ends and
you're like [ __ ]
what
that reminds me
man what was that show
it was kind of similar to ozark
it had
damn
it was on netflix
i think
it's kind of similar it was like some
people staying at a vacation home and
their brother owned a
boating shack yeah bloodline yeah that
[ __ ] slapped
i loved that show